une loi climat et résilience l'abandon
de projets controversés comme l'aéroport
de notre dame des landes où le centre
commercial europa city bientôt un wan ho
shon subite après un one planet subite
emmanuel macron n'a pas chômé sur les
questions environnementales
depuis le début de son quinquennat à
marseille emmanuel macron étaient
présents le 3 septembre pour l'ouverture
du congrès mondial de la nature
l'occasion pour le chef de l'état de
valoriser son action environnementale
nous serons les premiers le 1er janvier
prochain
à ne plus avoir de plastique autour de
nos fruits de nos légumes et tout ce qui
pèse moins d'un kilo et demi bien et il
y aura un conditionnement qui ne sera
plus un conditionnement plastiques ce
que je vais annoncer cet après midi au
congrès mondial de la nature c'est une
multiplication par 25
des aires maritimes à très forte
protection ses terres maritime naturel
aujourd'hui à très fort protection c'est
un choix qui est important parce que ça
veut dire ce sont des espaces on ne fait
plus de punch etc mais l'enthousiasmé du
président n'est pas partagé par tout le
monde à commencer par son ancien
ministre de l'écologie nicolas hulot
pour qui une part dérisoire du plan de
relance a été assigné à la question de
la biodiversité
il faut une radicalité programme et je
demande avec tous les acteurs de la
biodiversité un électrochoc actuellement
dans le plan de relance 0,25 pour cent
sont consacrés à la biodiversité c'est
largement insuffisant
non c'est beaucoup plus parce que tout
le plan protéines tout le plan de
mécanisation par exemple du monde
agricole 7 pour la biodiversité ce que
fait le ministre de l'agriculture à
travers le plan de relance avec des
montants importants
on l'a dit ce plan de relance il était
avant tout un plan de relance vers le
site d'information reporter dresse un
bilan mitigé du quinquennat d' emmanuel
macron sur la question de la
biodiversité dans son viseur entre
autres la bienveillance des autorités
envers plusieurs projets controversés
comme le contournement autoroutier de
strasbourg les projets gaziers de total
en arctique les appels du pied aux
chasseurs ou encore l'implantation
d'entrepôts du géant américain amazon le
gouvernement est aussi accusé d'avoir
contribué par le biais de plusieurs
mesures à la dérégulation de normes
environnementales sous couvert de
simplification administrative
autant d'éléments qui laissent un goût
amer dans la bouche des militants
écologistes
l'exécutif n'a pas voulu toucher au
modèle agro-industriel
le mandat du président macron ne laisse
pas d'empreinte écologique
comme toujours avec emmanuel macron
l'objectif revendiqué est de concilier
des forces contraires avec une bonne
dose de communication pour arrondir les
angles mais lorsqu'ils font le tri entre
les grandes déclarations et l'évolution
réelle de la situation
deux défenseurs de l'environnement
restent sur leur faim